we set up in July 2019 just before
covert so we had nine months before the
pandemic hit yeah so I'm obviously we
know that the pandemic if you're in your
first year of business that really
really wasn't ideal so that was
challenging but let's not talk about
that for sure so that that nine months
in in the kind of run up to the pandemic
the most difficult thing honestly that I
would say it was the isolation of I was
literally just working at my kitchen
table
I'm a sociable person I have to be
around people I can't be alone with my
own brain for too long because before I
know it I'm overthinking wow my
Gardener's not turned up today and I'm
like what like what's wrong with me so
for my motivation and I realized quite
early on
I always thought I'd be this one woman
band but quite early on I'm thinking I
need I need staff I need a team I need
people around me or I need to go and
work with other people because I can't
be on my own all day it's no it's no fun
it's boring so that's what that's what
really I found tough and I met Sophia as
a Sophia was my first member of staff
and I met her when the business was only
four months old but I wanted to make
sure that I had at least six months of
her salary in the bank so that if
anything did happen I you know I'd give
her time to get up and running she
didn't have any experience I didn't know
how well I would bring somebody on
um so I said to a look as soon as I've
got this amount of money in the bank the
job's yours she was working for the for
a local college so she was in this dead
stable job and then obviously we said
April would be a good time for it to
start and then obviously she hadn't
noticing the day after we're going to
lockdown and I ran going I was like eh
Baba notice
a dragon you can like retract it and
just kind of like stay because I was
just thinking the risk we all my jobs
had literally just been canceled and I'm
like oh you don't know how things in the
playoff honestly it was like bonkers the
time the way the timings were she handed
it in the next day the country's locked
down so she was I honestly don't know
what it was that made her stick with it
because we've been having these
conversations since the October before
she started the following July wow so
but she was just determined she really
wanted to be a part of it the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by vincere and the
award-winning Source breaker